a cake for a little girl being allowed
to fight on and a celebration for a
family who battled for her and one to
feed Iraqis bed is now surrounded with
balloons and with hope but just four
months ago her doctor said her brain
damage was permanent and that
withdrawing life supporting treatment
was in her best interests
her family disagreed and fought for her
in court
surrounded by their family and legal
team the relief of her parents is clear
it has they say been aa traumatic
journey every single day I actually
didn't vote down and I was petrified I'm
scared what is it gonna be what is he
gonna do what do you thinking of is it
gonna be a life sentence if it is gonna
get also gonna be a death sentence to be
that's gonna receive every month is to
say it's to say they plan to move to
feed it to a specialist Children's
Hospital in Italy where they believe her
care will be better and they'll have a
greater say the value children's lives
they don't give up on children and then
they also cause with our religious
belief as well so that's where it's
different to feed her collapsed in
February after complaining of headaches
and suffered ruptured blood vessels in
her brain in court her parents argued
that while she cannot be cured she's
continually improving the judge rejected
doctor's view the treatment would cause
further physical degradation he ruled
she was in no pain and that her parents
opinions should be considered the
judgment will have implications for
families in similar situations for
chelina legislation is now essential the
government needs to revisit the
Children's Act the government needs to
revisit the law so that another family
doesn't go through
we have or what the previous families
have gone through parent or rights
should never be taken away her family
want to feed her moved as soon as
possible while now is a moment for joy
they know the road ahead of them will be
long and hard everyone needs to give be
given time and then energy that will
prove everyone who has come across her
how wrong they were Helen Anne Smith Sky
News